i grew up actually in um  in a little town out in the outskirts of  buenos aires i'm not a porteno i'm a  bona density i'm from the province of  buenos aires and i actually lived  perhaps five blocks away from a movie  theater  so  i um  i saw a lot of movies especially in the  summer even you know  not only in the weekends but during the  week  sometimes i show three movies in a row i  do have some movies that made a big  impression when i was a kid and one of  them was a musical was west side story  you know the robert weiss  movie and  with the music of leonard bernstein and  and the other one was lawrence of arabia  you know with that wonderful music by  maurice jar